A century ago the apocalyptic abounded and it
echoes in today's political discourse. Activist
progressives have a history of apocalypticism
on issues like climate change, but now some on
the political right have been captivated by these
very same impulses. The problem with apocalyptic
politics is two-fold: it corrupts public life
by reducing the non-political complexity of life
to political warfare and secondly, it blinds
us to everything that's actually going well.
So what came of the apocalyptism of the 1920s?
Well in the wake of the great depression and
World War II, imaginative thought leaders focused
on what was good and true in western civilization.
And America experienced the flowering of literary
cultural and economic progress. So what are the
good things hiding in plain sight today? From a
newfound awareness of the importance of marriage
and faith, to American's strong sense of place
patriotism and belief in the American dream,
to a robust embrace of education
innovation and medical breakthroughs.
It is the recoverists who will find each
other and defend the first principles,
practices, and institutions on which all of these
good things depend. So how worried are you about
America's future let us know in our poll. Also let
us know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover In 60 Seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.